une nuit sous le signe de l'embrasement
l'assassinât dimanche du célèbre
militant anti gouvernementales et à
bâloise ni a provoqué la colère dans
plusieurs villes du sud du pays
la nuit dernière ahmad hassan
journaliste de la chaîne irakienne al
fourat a été victime d'une tentative
d'assassinât
il se trouve actuellement en soins
intensifs après avoir reçu deux balles
dans la tête et une autre dans l'épaule
dans les rues la tension monte alors que
la colère s'intensifie en réaction à ces
assassinats politiques
plusieurs feux ont été déclenchés ces
deux dernières nuits à kerbala
la police assure que la situation est
sous contrôle la situation sécuritaire
dans le gouvernorat de kerbala et bonne
grâce à dieu je suis ici maintenant
devant le consulat iranien avec le
commandant des opérations avec la
présence des régiments d'urgence et des
forces de briseurs de grève
la situation est bonne comme vous pouvez
le voir la route est ouverte et
net-citoyens se déplacent librement et
en général la situation dans le
gouvernorat de kerbala est bonne si dieu
le veut
si la police se veut rassurante ce n'est
pas le cas des manifestants ces derniers
demandent des comptes et accuse la
police et le gouverneur de la ville
d'être derrière l'assassinât du militant
et à bâloise ne nous demandons au chef
de la police de révéler l'identité des
assassins de l'activiste arabe el
ouazzani qui a manifesté de 2000 cas
jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour le droit du
peuple irakien pourquoi at il été tué
pendant le mois de ramadan nous tenons
pour responsable le gouverneur de
kerbala
le chef de la police et le commandant
des opérations s ils ne veulent pas
assumer cette responsabilité ils doivent
révéler qui est le tueur
sinon ce sont eux qui sont responsables
de l'assassinât et abalo hasseni
dénonçait depuis plusieurs années les
groupes armés ainsi que le contrôle de
l'iran sur la ville chiite de kerbala
la mort du militant à laquelle s'ajoute
la tentative d'assassinât d'ahmed hassan
interviennent alors que des élections
législatives anticipées doivent avoir
lieu en octobre
un scrutin qui avait été premier au
peuple
à la suite d'un mouvement de
contestation en octobre 2019 ce
mouvement appelé révolution d'octobre
avait été durement réprimées causant la
mort de près de 600 manifestants irakien
[Applaudissements]